Ronnie doesn't know it but Ronnie is so
great
and I'm going to tell you why he's great
so you know something set Ronnie off the
thing that sets Ronnie off the most
is when people say elderly to him Ronnie
you didn't even know this over the
summer the guys called Ronnie at home I
didn't know anything during that quote I
lost my [__] this is the greatest moment
of my summer this is why I couldn't wait
to get back on the air just to play it
first of all this proves that Ronnie is
just an ornery guy I mean he will yell
at anyone I thought the people on this
phony phone call were very nice they're
calling Ronnie saying look we know your
age it's part of the government service
to check in on the elderly and make sure
you're okay yeah yeah but when Ronnie is
that they're checking up on him for
being elderly he goes [__] berserk
you should have been in my house when
this was going on Stephanie was working
in the office she came flying out of the
office and said what the hell is going
on here here's Ronnie being called at
home with the government trying to help
him out because he's elderly here you go
well hello Mr Mund and my name is
Shirley St Germain I work for the
devener Services we're just calling
certain individuals to make sure that
they're faring well during these extreme
weather events yeah we're fine thank you
we have no problem everything's good
here and you've been drinking enough
water to stay hydrated yes all good
thank you I just want to make sure that
you don't need a Meals on Wheels person
to come by to your house no I don't no I
don't everything's fine okay perfect and
do you have a pool to cool off in this
weather yes I just want to make sure are
there special bars that you have to get
in and out safely
man everything is fine okay please
I'm sorry sir it does sound a bit like
you're in distress this could be a sign
of heat stroke I am not in distress okay
I'm fine I mean being I'm being in
distress because you're asking me all
these questions that I don't want to
answer the way you're acting now is a
sign of heat stroke I want to make sure
that you know that we do have cooling
centers for seniors in the area if your
house is not properly cooled I have a
brand new house brand new pool what else
would you like to know would you like to
know what time I wake up in the morning
sir please stay calm we can send help if
you need it I am going to hang up the
phone right now and stop calling me
please
personal I just want to know how are
your stools are they black or are they
Brown and normal foreign
a supervisor was monitoring my call and
because of your temperament on the call
she advised us to send a caseworker to
your house right away just to confirm
that you are not having no there's no
place work coming to my house what don't
you understand about have a wife here I
have a wife here I have a job okay I'm
very functional I am fine okay I drive a
car I do everything okay I'm not I'm not
broken down and old okay you got to stop
this you got to stop these phone calls
you sound healthy but because of your
age we do have to check up on you it is
our responsibility no I'm not and
nobody's going to answer nobody's going
to talk to you okay this is ridiculous
we're just sending someone down there to
check and they're just gonna there's
another three more questions you are not
sending anyone here because no one will
the door they're just going to make sure
that the home is cool do you know what
do you want to do a problem is there
someone else in the house that I could
speak to perhaps a caregiver
what is your problem I have a wife here
what is going on with you and is your
wife also mobile is she does she take
care why is she in charge of the
medicine my wife is 40 years old okay so
she is sort of a a caregiver for you
then can I speak to your supervisor
please let me speak to you supervisor
this is ridiculous
um I would maybe have to put you on hold
for just a moment I want to speak to
your supervisor Miss I want to speak to
your supervisor what is the problem with
you okay just one moment sir please stay
calm I'm not oh stop it
this is the supervisor Mason yes who am
I speaking with uh this lady whoever I'm
speaking to I explaining everything in
my house it's a brand new house brand
new pool and you're harassing me right
now okay do you have a hearing device
connected to your phone I'm afraid
you're just a little bit low are you do
you require any assistance using the uh
the handheld device no I don't I don't
I'm on a cell phone okay can you hear me
all right yeah I can hear you fine
you're not hearing impaired sir
no I'm not are you calling from a rotary
telephone sir excuse me do I have to
call the police on you what is your
problem
[Laughter]
you turned into a Karen let me speak to
your supervisor that was great somebody
speak to your supervisor and how are you
gonna call the police on the social
services I don't know
I'm calling the police